قامت القوات الأوكرانية بتقدم كبير
في منطقة زاباريزا الجنوبية أثناء
محاولتها اختراق
خط المواجهة الروسي المحصن بشدة والملغوم بشدة. ما تعلمناه من
المسؤولين الروس والتقارير هو أن
القوات الأوكرانية استخدمت حوالي 100
مركبة مدرعة في هذا التقدم بما في ذلك  تلك
الدبابات الألمانية الصنع من طراز ليوبارد 2، التي
صنعتها أمريكا مركبات برادلي القتالية،
كانت هذه الجبهة ذات أولوية رئيسية في هذا
الهجوم المضاد على مدى الأسابيع القليلة الماضية
منذ أن بدأ، وقد رأينا
القوات الأوكرانية تتقدم على طول تلك
الجبهة الجنوبية في محاولة لاختراقها
وفي الآونة الأخيرة  لقد حققوا بعض
المكاسب المتواضعة في أماكن أخرى على طول
الجبهة الجنوبية. اليوم شاهدنا مقطع فيديو
للقوات الروسية الفارة من القتال وهي
تنسحب من الجانب الأوكراني،
ومؤخرًا قضينا بعض الوقت على تلك
الجبهة الجنوبية مع اللواء الميكانيكي 47،
وهو أحد القوات الأوكرانية.
الألوية التي تلقت تدريبًا أمريكيًا في
ألمانيا تلقوا
مركبات برادلي القتالية وأخبرونا
الليلة أنهم يستخدمون ذلك
التدريب المشترك على الأسلحة والمناورة الذي
تعلموه من الأمريكيين أن
جنودهم يتقدمون سيرًا على الأقدام
تحت غطاء المدفعية الأوكرانية
وفي الوقت نفسه تلك الألوية من برادلي
تقوم المركبات القتالية بتدمير مواقع المشاة الروسية
بالإضافة إلى المعدات الروسية،
لكن مع تقدم أوكرانيا في
الجنوب، ما زلنا نرى روسيا
تهاجم جميع أنحاء أوكرانيا من السماء
بعشرات الصواريخ التي أطلقت على أوكرانيا في جميع
أنحاء البلاد اليوم، كما
يقول سلاح الجو الأوكراني.  أنه تم إسقاط حوالي 40 صاروخًا روسيًا، وكانت هناك
صواريخ كروز استخدمت
صواريخ كينزال التي تفوق سرعتها سرعة الصوت، وتم إطلاق أربعة منها على الأقل
أيضًا،
وقالت القوات الجوية الأوكرانية إن الصواريخ الروسية
دخلت المجال الجوي الأوكراني من
الجنوب الشرقي واتجهت غربًا
وتغير اتجاهها باستمرار ولكن  لقد شهدنا
مؤخرًا موجة من الضربات في
أوديسا، حتى لو تم إسقاط الصواريخ،
فمن الممكن أن تحدث أضرارًا كبيرة على
الأرض حيث يؤدي الحطام المتساقط إلى إيذاء أو
قتل الناس.
الشرق ولكن تواجه
مقاومة شرسة في وقت قريب، يبدو أن هذا الفيديو
يظهر القوات الأوكرانية التي تسيطر
على مواقع روسية جنوب
مدينة المحيط الهادئ. سي إن إن غير قادرة على
تأكيد التفاصيل بشكل مستقل وفي الوقت نفسه،
تنكر أوكرانيا خسائرها
في الجزء الشمالي الشرقي من البلاد
منذ أن حاول روبسون العرقي
لفهم جميع الرسائل التي
نتلقاها من كلا الجانبين، وأنت تعلم وجود
فراغ في المعلومات في بعض المناطق أيضًا،
نعم فراغ في المعلومات محاط
بالدعاية
أم ما نفهمه مما يحدث
حول باخمان، فنحن نعلم أنه منذ أواخر
الربيع لدى الأوكرانيين  يحاولون
التجول في الشمال وحول
جنوب المدينة لأنهم لا
يريدون القتال في طريقهم عبر المدينة وستكون
الفكرة هي أنهم يستطيعون
محاصرة المدينة جيدًا، فهم لا
يحققون مكاسب سريعة بشكل خاص ولكن
لأن  المكاسب التي يحققونها هي
في الواقع الطريقة التي قاتلت بها وكان من
الصعب علي الاحتفاظ بمواقعهم،
ويبدو للجنوب كما لو أنهم
تمكنوا من التقدم خلال
الشهرين الماضيين ربما بضعة كيلومترات وفي
كثير من الأحيان كنا هناك في وقت سابق  في
العام ستقول إحدى الوحدات حسنًا، لقد استولينا على تلك
الأرض ثم تم تسليم وحدة أخرى
إليهم ثم فقدوها
وكان علينا العودة للاستيلاء عليها
مرة أخرى، لذلك كان هذا النوع من
الهجوم على الشمال لذا  أرجع إلى ما
يدعي الروس أنهم
يكتسبونه قليلاً من الأرض
ويدفعون الأوكرانيين إلى الخلف على طول
جانب الخزان إلى شمال
المدينة، وإذا نظرنا مرة أخرى إلى الوراء وقارنوا ذلك
بالخطوط كما كانت في أواخر
الربيع
ربما لم يتحركوا كثيراً  الكثير ولكن هذا هو
المجال الذي يعتقد الأوكرانيون أنهم
يحققونه مرة أخرى، أو يكتسبون بعض
المزايا في ساحة المعركة التي
يقولون إن الروس يعززونها
بشكل كبير.